[Musique]
le bobsleigh hier un loisir un peu
excentrique avec un équipement
rudimentaire
aujourd'hui c'est une discipline
spectaculaire
des engins qui fendent l'air
un cocktail de sciences prix
d'adrénaline
chamonix 1924 les départs se font à 6
pour accélérer on se balance à l'unisson
ce mouvement en anglais pab donnera son
nom au sport
mais la technique sera vite abandonné au
fil du temps les athlètes vont enfin se
lever pour participer à la poussée il
mise désormais sur leur puissance pour
mettre en branle un traîneau de 200 kg
la technologie leur viennent en aide
souliers à crampons vêtements moulants
et poignée rétractable
résultat une chorégraphie réglée au
quart de tour
cette impulsion et crucial
la gravité un effet multiplicateur un
gain d'un dixième de seconde et par
deviennent trois dixièmes à la risée à
condition bien sûr de conserver sa
vitesse pour y arriver le sport connaît
une deuxième métamorphose celle du
traîneau
rapidement le volant cède sa place un
système de cordes et de poulies pour un
pilotage tout en finesse
car tout est dans l'art de prendre des
cours trop haut on allonge la
trajectoire mais un virage trop serré
augmente la flexion et réduit la vitesse
pour fendre l'air on ajoute d'abord une
coque à l'avant du traîneau
puis un fuselage qui recouvre tout
l'arrière l'ensemble des plus
aérodynamique et plus sécuritaire
[Applaudissements]
sous la carrosserie on retrouve les deux
sections d'origine l'arrière plus l'on
supporte le poids des athlètes
à l'avant les patins permettent de
diriger le traîneau mais ils peuvent
aussi pivoter un peu comme une
suspension
ce mouvement torsion permet de mieux
épouser la forme des cours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les athlètes plus en caisse aujourd'hui
jusqu'à 5g cinq fois leur poids les
mêmes et 135 km 1 heure pas question de
freiner avant d'avoir franchi la ligne
d'arrivée
car depuis un siècle une chose n'a pas
changé pour exceller au bobsleigh
il faut avant tout avoir des nerfs
d'acier